à une vue fonctionnelle de la géographie,
ce qui correspond à la manière dont on utilise le monde,
des pays et frontières, à l'infrastructure et à la logistique.
Notre système global est en train d'évoluer
d'empires du 19ème siècle, intégrés verticalement,
puis des pays du 20ème siècle, horizontalement interdépendants,
vers une civilisation mondiale en réseau, au 21ème siècle.
La connectivité, et non souveraineté,
est devenue le principe d'organisation de l'espèce humaine.
(Applaudissements)
Nous devenons cette civilisation mondiale en réseau
car nous sommes en train de la construire.
L'ensemble des dépenses militaires
s'élèvent à un peu moins de 2000 milliards de dollars par an.
Pendant ce temps, nos dépenses d'infrastructure mondiale
devrait atteindre 9000 milliards de dollars par an
d'ici la prochaine décennie.
Et heureusement d'ailleurs.
Nous avons dépendu d'une infrastructure
faite pour une population mondiale de trois milliards,
et notre population dépasse sept milliards pour atteindre huit
et sans doute neuf, et plus encore.
En règle générale, nous devrions dépenser environ 1000 milliards de dollars
sur les besoins simples d'infrastructure par milliard d'individus.
Sans surprise, l'Asie est en tête.
En 2015, la Chine a annoncé la création
de la Banque Asiatique d'Investissement pour les Infrastructures,
qui avec d'autres organisations
vise à construire un réseau de routes d'acier et de soie,
allant de Shanghai à Lisbonne.
Et comme toutes ces topographies d'ingénierie se déploient,
nous dépenserons probablement plus dans
l'infrastructure pendant les 40 prochaines années,
nous construirons plus d'infrastructures au cours des 40 prochaines années,
qu'au cours des 4 000 dernières années.
Arrêtons-nous et pensons à tout ça un instant.
Dépenser beaucoup plus sur la construction des fondations d'une société mondiale
plutôt que sur les outils pour la détruire
peut avoir de profondes conséquences.
La connectivité est la manière dont on optimise la distribution
des gens et ressources sur Terre.
C'est ce qui fait que l'humanité devient plus que la somme de ses parties.
Je crois que c'est cela qui est en train de se passer.
La connectivité a une tendance jumelle au 21ème siècle :
l'urbanisation planétaire.
Les villes sont les infrastructures qui nous définissent le plus.
D'ici 2030, plus de deux tiers de la population mondiale
vivra en ville.
Et ce ne sont pas de simples points sur une carte,
mais un vaste archipel s'étendant sur des centaines de kilomètres.
Nous sommes à Vancouver,
tout au nord du Couloir de Cascadie
qui s'étend au sud à travers la frontière américaine jusqu'à Seattle.
Le poumon technologique de la Sillicon Valley
commence au nord de San Francisco et se termine à San Jose
et traverse la baie d'Oakland.
L'extension urbaine de Los Angeles dépasse maintenant San Diego,
et traverse la frontière Mexicaine jusqu'à Tijuana.
San Diego et Tijuana partagent maintenant un terminal d'aéroport
duquel vous pouvez sortir dans les deux pays.
Un train à grande vitesse pourrait un jour relier la colonne vertébrale du Pacifique.
La mégalopole américaine du nord-est commence à Boston, traverse New York
et Philadelphie, et arrive à Washington.
Elle contient plus de 50 millions d'habitants
et prévoit aussi la mise en place d'un train à grande vitesse.
Mais c'est en Asie où l'on peut réellement observer les mégalopes se créer.
Cette bande de lumière continue de Tokyo, à travers Nagoya et Osaka
représente plus de 80 millions d'habitants
et la majorité de l'économie du Japon.
C'est la plus grande mégapole au monde.
A ce jour.
Mais en Chine, des mégalopoles sont en train de se constituer
atteignant une population de 100 millions d'habitants.
Le Bohai Rim autour de Pékin,
le Delta du Yangtsé autour de Shanghai
et le Delta de la rivière des Perles,
s'étendant du nord de Hong-Kong jusqu'à Canton.
Et au milieu,
le groupe de mégapoles de Chengdu–Chongqing,
donc l'emprise géographique est presque de même taille
que celle d'un pays comme l'Autriche.
Et chacun de ces groupes de mégapoles
a un PIB atteignant les 2000 milliards de dollars --
c'est presque l'équivalent de celui de l'Inde aujourd'hui.
Imaginez si nos institutions diplomatiques mondiales, comme le G20,
basaient leur adhésion sur des critères économiques
plutôt que sur la représentation nationale.
Certaines mégapoles chinoises pourraient être assises autour de la table,
alors que des pays, comme l'Argentine ou l'Indonésie partiraient.
Regardons l'Inde, dont la population dépassera bientôt celle de la Chine,
elle a aussi plusieurs groupes de mégapoles,
comme la région de Delhi
et Mumbai.
Au Moyen-Orient,
le Grand Téhéran contient un tiers de la population de l'Iran.
La majorité des 80 millions d'habitants de l’Égypte
vit sur un axe entre Le Caire et Alexandrie.
Et dans le golfe, un collier de villes-états se forme,
du Bahrain et du Qatar,
à travers les Émirats Arabes Unis jusqu'à Mascate à Oman.
Et puis il y a Lagos,
La plus grande ville d'Afrique et la plaque commerciale du Nigeria.
Elle a un plan pour un réseau ferré
ce qui en fera l'ancre d'un vaste couloir côtier atlantique,
s'étendant à travers le Bénin, le Togo et le Ghana,
jusqu'à Abidjan, la capitale de la Côte d'Ivoire.
Mais ces pays ne sont que des banlieues de Lagos.
Dans un monde de mégapoles,
les pays peuvent être des banlieues de villes.
D'ici 2030, nous aurons 50 groupes de mégalopoles dans le monde.
Donc quelle carte vous en dit le plus?
Notre carte traditionnelle de 200 nations distinctes,
accrochée sur la plupart de nos murs,
ou bien cette carte indiquant les 50 groupes de mégapoles ?
Et pourtant, même cette carte est incomplète,
car vous ne pouvez comprendre aucune de ces mégapoles
sans comprendre ses connexions avec les autres.
Les gens migrent vers les villes pour être connectés,
et la connectivité est la raison pour laquelle les villes prospèrent.
N'importe laquelle d'entre elles, Sao Paulo, Istanbul ou Moscou,
a un PIB approchant ou dépassant le tiers ou la moitié
du PIB de leur pays.
Et, non moins important,
vous ne pouvez calculer aucune de leur valeur individuelle
sans comprendre le rôle des flux des personnes,
de la finance, de la technologie
qui leur permettent de prospérer.
Prenez la province du Gauteng en Afrique du Sud,
qui inclut Johannesburg et la capitale, Pretoria.
Elle représente un peu plus du tiers du PIB d'Afrique du Sud.
Mais, non moins important, c'est aussi le siège social
de la quasi-totalité des multinationales
qui investissent directement en Afrique du Sud,
et de fait, dans le continent africain dans son ensemble.
Les villes veulent faire partie des chaînes de valeur mondiales.
Elles veulent faire partie de cette division mondiale du travail.
C'est ainsi que les villes réfléchissent.
Je n'ai jamais entendu un maire me dire :
« Je veux que ma ville soit isolée. »
Ils savent que leur ville appartient autant à la civilisation en réseau mondial
qu'à leur propre pays.
Cependant, pour beaucoup de personnes, l'urbanisation cause un grand désarroi.
Ils pensent que les villes ruinent la planète.
Mais aujourd'hui,
il y a plus de 200 réseaux d'apprentissage entre villes qui se développent.
C'est tout autant que le nombre d'organisations intergouvernementales
qui existent aujourd'hui.
Et tous ces réseaux interurbains se concentrent sur une seule chose,
la priorité numéro une de l'humanité en ce 21ème siècle :
l'urbanisation durable.
Est-ce que ça marche ?
Prenons le changement climatique.
Nous savons que sommet après sommet, à New York et à Paris,
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre ne diminuent pas.
Mais ce que nous voyons; c'est que le transfert de technologies,
de connaissances et de politiques entre les villes
nous ont permis de commencer à réduire l'intensité carbone de nos économies.
Les villes apprennent les unes des autres.
Comment construire des bâtiments « zéro émission »,
déployer des systèmes de partage de voitures électriques.
Dans les villes majeures chinoises,
on impose des quotas sur le nombre de voitures dans les rues.
Dans beaucoup de villes occidentales,
les jeunes gens ne veulent même plus conduire.
Les villes ont été une part du problème,
maintenant elles sont une part de la solution.
L'inégalité est l'autre grand challenge pour réussir l'urbanisation durable.
Lorsque je parcours ces mégapoles en long, en large et en travers —
ce qui prend des heures et des jours —
je ressens la tragédie de la disparité extrême
au sein d'une même géographie.
Et pourtant, notre stock mondial d'actifs financiers
n'a jamais été aussi important,
approchant 300 000 milliards de dollars.
C'est presque quatre fois le PIB mondial.
Nous avons réussi à recouvrer des dettes énormes depuis la crise financière,
mais les avons-nous investies dans une croissance durable ?
Non, pas encore.
Mais construire un nombre suffisant de logements sociaux abordables,
investir dans des réseaux de transport robustes
pour permettre aux gens de se connecter à la fois physiquement et numériquement,
c'est cela qui permettra à nos villes et sociétés fragmentées
de se sentir unies de nouveau.
(Applaudissements)
Et c'est pourquoi l'infrastructure vient juste d'être rajoutée
dans les Objectifs de Développement Durable des Nations-Unies,
car elle est un catalyseur pour tous les autres.
Nos leaders politiques et économiques
sont en train de comprendre que connectivité ne rime pas avec charité,
mais avec opportunité.
C'est pourquoi notre communauté financière a besoin de comprendre
que la connectivité est la classe d'actif la plus importante du 21ème siècle.
Aujourd'hui, les villes peuvent rendre le monde plus durable,
elles peuvent rendre le monde plus équitable,
je pense également que la connectivité entre les villes
peut rendre le monde plus apaisé.
Si on observe les régions du monde avec des relations transfrontalières denses,
nous voyons plus de commerce, d'investissement
et plus de stabilité.
Nous savons tous l'histoire de l'Europe après la 2ème Guerre Mondiale,
quand l'intégration industrielle a initié un processus
qui a conduit à l'Union Européenne apaisée d'aujourd'hui.
Et vous pouvez constater que la Russie, d'ailleurs,
est la moins connectée des grandes puissances
du système international.
Et cela contribue grandement à expliquer les tensions d'aujourd'hui.
Les pays qui ont le moins d'enjeux dans le système
ont également le moins à perdre à le perturber.
En Amérique du Nord, les lignes qui comptent le plus sur la carte
ne sont pas les frontières entre les États-Unis et le Canada ou le Mexique,
mais le dense réseau de routes, de chemins de fer et de pipelines,
et les réseaux électriques, et même les canaux,
qui dessinent une union Nord Américaine intégrée.
L'Amérique du Nord n'a pas besoin de plus de murs mais plus de connexions.
(Applaudissements)
Mais la vraie promesse de la connectivité est dans le monde postcolonial.
Toutes ces régions où les frontières ont été définies le plus arbitrairement,
et où des générations de leaders
ont eu entre eux des relations hostiles.
A présent un nouveau groupe de leaders a pris le pouvoir
et enterre la hache de guerre.
Prenez l'Asie du sud-est, où des réseaux ferrés à grande vitesse
relient Bangkok à Singapour,
et les couloirs commerciaux du Vietnam à la Birmanie.
Cette région de 600 millions d'habitants coordonne ses ressources agricoles
et sa production industrielle.
C'est en train d'évoluer vers ce que j'appelle la « Pax Asiana »,
la paix parmi les nations de l'Asie du Sud-Est.
Un phénomène similaire est en cours en Afrique de l'Est,
où une demi-douzaine de pays
investissent dans les réseaux ferrés et les couloirs multimodaux ;
ainsi, les pays enclavés peuvent envoyer leurs marchandises sur le marché.
Aujourd'hui, ces pays coordonnent leurs services
et leurs politiques d'investissement.
Eux, également, évoluent vers une « Pax Africana ».
Une région que nous connaissons bien pourrait engager ce type de réflexion :
c'est le Moyen-Orient.
Comme les états arabes s'effondrent tragiquement,
que reste-t-il finalement sinon les anciennes cités,
telles que Le Caire, Beyrouth et Bagdad ?
En fait, les près de 400 millions d'habitants du monde arabe
sont presque totalement urbanisés.
En tant que sociétés, en tant que villes,
elles sont soit riches soit pauvres en eau,
riches ou pauvres en énergie.
Et le seul moyen de corriger ces inégalités
n'est pas à travers plus de guerres et plus de frontières,
mais à travers plus de connectivité de pipelines et de canaux.
Malheureusement, ce n'est pas encore la carte du Moyen-Orient.
Mais ça devrait l'être,
une « Pax Arabia » connectée,
intégrée en interne,
et productivement connectée à ses voisins : l'Europe, l'Asie et l'Afrique.
La connectivité ne semble pas être ce que nous souhaitons maintenant
pour la région la plus agitée du monde.
Mais nous savons tous historiquement que plus de connectivité est le seul moyen
d'apporter de la stabilité sur le long terme.
Car nous savons que région après région,
la connectivité est la nouvelle réalité.
Les villes et pays apprennent à s'agréger
en des ensembles plus paisibles et prospères.
Mais le vrai test sera l'Asie.
La connectivité peut-elle surmonter les modèles de rivalité
parmi les grandes puissances de l'Extrême Orient ?
Après tout, c'est là où la 3ème Guerre Mondiale est supposée éclater.
Depuis la fin de la Guerre Froide, il y a 25 ans,
on a prédit au moins 6 conflits majeurs dans cette région.
Mais aucun d'entre eux n'a eu lieu.
Prenez la Chine et Taiwan :
dans les années 90, c'était pour beaucoup le scénario conduisant
à la 3ème Guerre Mondiale.
Mais depuis, le commerce
et les volumes d'investissement à travers le détroit sont devenus si intenses
qu'en novembre dernier,
les leaders de chaque camp ont organisé un sommet historique
pour discuter d'une éventuelle réunification pacifique.
Et même l'élection du parti nationaliste à Taiwan,
favorable à l'indépendance, en début d'année
ne met pas en péril cette dynamique fondamentale.
La Chine et le Japon ont une rivalité encore plus longue,
et ont déployé leur forces maritimes et aériennes
pour montrer leur force lors de différends territoriaux.
Mais ces dernières années,
le Japon a réalisé ses plus grands investissements étrangers en Chine.
La vente de voitures japonaises y a atteint des chiffres record.
Et devinez d'où viennent le plus grand contingent d'étrangers
résidant au Japon aujourd'hui ?
Vous l'avez deviné : la Chine.
La Chine et l'Inde ont connu un conflit majeur
et ont toujours trois différends frontaliers,
mais l'Inde est aujourd'hui le 2ème actionnaire
de la Banque Asiatique d'Investissement pour les Infrastructures.
Ils construisent un couloir commercial s'étendant du Nord-Est indien
à travers la Birmanie et le Bangladesh jusqu'au sud de la Chine.
Leurs volumes commerciaux ont crû de 20 milliards de dollars il y a dix ans
à 80 milliards de dollars aujourd'hui.
L'Inde et le Pakistan, avec l'arme nucléaire, ont connu trois guerres
et continuent de se disputer le Cachemire,
mais ils négocient aussi un accord commercial contenant
une clause de nation de la plus favorisée
et veulent construire un pipeline
s'étendant de l'Iran, à travers le Pakistan, jusqu'en Inde.
Et parlons de l'Iran.
La guerre avec l'Iran ne semblait-elle pas inévitable il y a deux ans ?
Pourquoi chaque puissance majeure s'y rue aujourd'hui pour y faire des affaires ?
Mesdames et messieurs,
je ne peux pas garantir que la 3ème Guerre Mondiale n'éclatera pas.
Mais nous pouvons voir clairement pourquoi elle n'a toujours pas éclaté.
Même si l'Asie est la région du monde où les armées croissent le plus vite,
ces mêmes pays investissent également des milliards de dollars
dans leurs infrastructures et chaînes logistiques mutuelles.
Ils sont plus intéressés par la géographie fonctionnelle des autres pays
que par leur géographie politique.
C'est pourquoi leurs leaders réfléchissent à deux fois, se ressaisissent,
et décident de se concentrer sur les liens économiques
plutôt que sur les tensions territoriales.
Très souvent, il nous semble que le monde s'effondre,
mais construire plus de connectivité
est notre manière à nous de recoller les morceaux,
bien mieux qu'auparavant.
En enveloppant le monde
dans une connectivité harmonieuse, physique et digitale,
nous évoluons vers un monde
dans lequel les gens peuvent s'élever au dessus des contraintes géographiques.
Nous sommes les cellules et les vaisseaux
qui vivons à travers ces réseaux mondiaux de connectivité.
Chaque jour, des centaines de millions de personnes se connectent sur Internet
et travaillent avec des gens qu'ils n'ont jamais rencontrés.
Plus d'un milliard de personnes traversent les frontières chaque année,
et ce chiffre devrait atteindre trois milliards d'ici dix ans.
Nous ne construisons pas simplement la connectivité,
nous l'incarnons.
Nous sommes la civilisation du réseau mondial,
et ceci est notre carte.
Une carte du monde dans laquelle la géographie ne détermine plus le destin.
Au contraire, le futur a une devise nouvelle et remplie d'espoir :
la connectivité détermine le destin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)